woke Silicon Valley Bank donated over 73
million dollars to Black lives matter
related social justice groups before it
collapsed while failed Signature Bank
gave 850 000 so that's where your money
went
if you're wondering why Silicon Valley
Bank failed and where's your money at
there it is you can ask black lives
matter where your money went
money to ESG they bankrupted it and then
they just bail it out with taxpayer but
it's the most corrupt and you're in the
history but if this is recorded in the
history books which I hope it will be
it'll be seen as like the most
corruption understandable Financial
scandal in U.S history when the
Communist takeover happens in the United
States and lasts for 100 years or
whatever after it falls the people who
survive will write about how they took
over by using private institutions to
fund far-left extremism and then have
taxpayer dollars fund out those
organizations think about this a bank
gives 73 million dollars to far left
extremism
collapses the taxpayer bails them out
that's how you launder taxpayer money
into ideological subversion
crafty stuff it's like taxation without
representation
I didn't I didn't ask to be it's rather
my money set towards that crap well that
you didn't do your what they would say
is you didn't do your own research about
where this company is uh doing doing
business because they probably had a
prospectus or they probably put out a
prospectus that had all of this stuff
laid out but it's the taxpayer bailout
that I didn't I didn't sign up for right
tough but it's but it's but it's only a
government listen it's only sort of
taxpayer funded they're gonna use the
FDIC which is paid into from Banks but
they're supposed to use the money for
the little guy and they're giving it to
the billionaires and the millionaires
so it is it is taking away from you but
in a different way and how it affects a
taxpayer when they're like it's not
going to cost a taxpayer dime it will
not I repeat it will not they're lying
because what actually is going to happen
is the financial damage from all of this
is already Rippling out to everyone the
fact that stocks fell in these Banks
means retirement accounts are taking
hits and that means older people are
probably not looking at their budgets
being like I guess we don't eat this
month so yes it absolutely does hit
everybody when they do this and and
that's their argument is well we can't
have the social contagion or we can't
have the the banking contagion spread
around and destroy the economy can we I
say yeah we can well tough luck so the
average American household has ten
thousand dollars in cash in their
reserves East Palestine the median
household income was forty one thousand
dollars a year that's what normal
America that's how normal Americans live
now 95 of depositors had over the 250
000 maximum for federal insurance so you
were talking the Uber Rich of the Uber
Rich based on American based on the data
for American uh solvency right in
liquidity so you're talking the richest
of the rich this is a bailout of the
richest of the rich yep now these
deposits and they're woke too to me woke
as hell yeah if they were rich and
libertarian I might be like well they're
the laptop class that's right they're
the worst so you're taught so so put
this in context here it took the
government uh nion a month
to lift a finger for East Palestine
where they nuked a bunch of little
children and poisoned their water and
they had this they had this locked up by
Saturday Yellen had this done in an
emergency meeting by Saturday millions
of dollars nine in the morning mailing
out the richest and the wokest of the
woke because there's an owner Joe Biden
gets up at nine in the morning for an
emergency announcement and jensek is
like he doesn't do this Norm is a night
owl and I'm like this MFR flew across
the planet to give a half a billion
dollars to Ukraine and he didn't lift
the finger freeze Palestine but he wakes
up at the crack of dawn to make sure he
can assure all the woke Silicon Valley
investors your money's safe what a piece
of garbage but he's talking to the
people who vote for him and the people
who fund them and that's why he does it
the people of East Palestine voted for
Trump so he could give to
you're both right but but everybody here
knows that like to make the wealthy
suffer means that the poor suffer more
every single time like when if you if
you really want to hurt the wealthy if
you want and this is part of why
socialism doesn't work right like the
idea is get the money from the wealthy
right but when you get the money from
the wealthy the people that don't have
any money they get smashed and it's
literally that's why communism and
socialism doesn't work because when you
hurt the producers the wealthy are
always the ones that are producing like
the reason they have they have money and
stuff is because they're doing stuff so
as much as the incentive is like or the
gut feelings like make them suffer right
like that's what you want you want them
to pay but it's gonna hurt the poor
people and I'm not sure that it's worth
it I don't you know I don't want it I
don't want to suffer I don't want anyone
to suffer uh first and foremost the
major problem here the the major problem
here first and foremost is kind
institutional okay so article one and
two at the Constitution Congress
controls the purse Congress passed a law
to ensure 250 000 worth of deposits that
is a law by Congress how Joe Biden
has the bloody cheek to think that he
can just go through and rewrite this law
and spend this money and turn on this
faucet child balloon is beyond me now I
I tell you they did it with the vaccine
mandate they they did with student loans
they did it with student loans getting
smacked in the pp on both of those but
but here we here we go again he's
rewriting the constitution in real time
the ATF passed a law without Congress
they made an object illegal
uh braces for for pistols yes they're
saying that you can go to jail but they
never actually had Congress pass a law
Banning to an object these are all trial
balloons but more we're still there
grains of sand being added to the Heap
or the executive branch of the
government says we can make anything we
want legal or legal or illegal and no
one will stop us so it's not it's not
just the things you talked about but
you're correct right the the financial
stuff like the FDIC him saying I can
just give the money if I want what's he
gonna do about it the fact that he can
just take money and give it away
he didn't have those Powers but who will
stop him who's supposed to stop that's
exactly right he's supposed to start I
don't know Congress Congress Congress
report again people don't understand
Congress is article one Congress was
supposed to be the important Branch yeah
article two is the presidency That was
supposed to be like the Backwater
military yep that was supposed to be the
backboard that's why they put that's
where they put Old Washington in charge
Old Washington to kind of putts around
and talk to the talk to different
countries and talk about the talk about
the military into chew on his wooden
teeth and Congress was where the action
was and that's the way it was designed
because of course Congress itself is far
more representative of all of us you can
get a dumb ass president but it's hard
you know Congress is going to be a lot
uh when we saw this with the McCarthy
fight right Congress is going to be
where real populism happens dude we were
at Congress on Friday last Friday and
we're talking to Matt Gates and totally
Banning came in yeah and Steve band was
like get ready guys because on Monday
they're going to come in and they're
going to start asking you that they need
this bailout it was the next morning
they did it without Congress
they didn't ask that's I so so silly
poor silly Steve Bannon who thought they
would actually go to Congress this time
to ask instead they just went that's
right it's done that's right that
indicates that they're gonna do it again
in some other fashion that they'll be
like oh your dollars that you thought
were dollars their their digital
currency now don't ask questions right
and who's supposed to question let me
tell you Congress let me tell you a
story let me tell you a story uh I have
a Spanish friend and in 2012 at the end
of 2012 I went to Spain because they're
having big protests and I asked my
Spanish activist friend why the protests
had been going on and persisting and she
told me it all started with the Euro so
this is many years ago for these young
people unemployment why unemployment was
so very high why the economy was
destroyed and what she said was the
currency of Spain was I think it was the
passetta is that what it was and you'd
go out to your new if you wake up in the
morning you'd go to your Cafe you'd grab
a newspaper you'd grab a muffin or
something in a coffee and each of those
I the newspaper was one the muffin was
one the coffee was one three passetta
and you got everything you need then
they decided to roll out the Euro and
they wanted it normalized for all of
Europe she said one day they woke up and
the newspaper cost one Euro instead the
muffin cost one Euro and the coffee cost
one Euro the only problem is in order to
actually buy the Euro you needed three
percent per one Euro so all of your
goods everything jumped up three times
their cost overnight and then all of a
sudden the economy started falling apart
and then young people couldn't find jobs
they went into a financial crisis
started protesting with the Central Bank
digital currency we may see something
similar but perhaps they will try and
incentivize people into giving up their
freedom by saying well if you click the
I agree button on the app you get 1.5
times your deposit yeah so if you had a
hundred dollars in the bank you'll have
150 fed coin and fedcoin can be used
anywhere because it is legal tender and
must be accepted by all businesses oh
and they'll be like if you don't buy
gasoline this month we'll pay you a
thousand dollars kind of crap oh oh oh
oh oh yeah fed coin centralized Command
Bank is going to have like a thing where
it's like you can opt in for lower my
energy costs and then it'll be like it
will show you your coins going up very
slowly and it'll be like by not using
electricity you're earning and then it
will show you the coin you'll flip your
lights off and it'll tick a little
faster and then you'll be like oh all
the things I can and really what it is
it's the amount of money that they take
out of your per month
because while it's going up what they're
not telling you is they're also in
inflating the coin by producing more so
it's not really going up yeah that's the
thing about these they're not going to
be in a blockchain the Central Bank get
digital currencies are not planned from
what I've read to be on the blockchain
so there's not gonna be trackable no
one's going to know what they'll feed
into the background yeah they'll be
printing it we won't know that's the
best there's no there's no incentive for
the government to put their currency I
mean right now the the odd we can't get
the Federal Reserve audited never mind
control over the Federal Reserve there's
no way a federal coin is going to be on
a public open blockchain that's why
that's why Bitcoin is great like as much
as people want to go ahead and crap on
crypto and stuff like that I get it
there people don't understand it
whatever
um the great thing about Bitcoin is the
fact that it's decentralized that it's
International that it's not controlled
by anyone there's no single entity that
controls it and I I know that there's
people super focused on like the dollar
amount of a coin that's not what the
important part of Bitcoin is Bitcoin is
a protocol like email except right
Bitcoin may be the precursor intent
designed to bring about Central
centralized digital currencies in that
for the for for all Global Currency
there is gold gold is a store of value
Bitcoin they say is digital gold and
everybody agrees but Bitcoin they say is
digital gold and so maybe these Powers
wanted Bitcoin to exist they wanted
people to get very very wealthy off of
it they wanted to have an idea in the
public that if you bought Bitcoin you
were rich now then when they roll out
fedcoin they're going to be like don't
miss the train because if you buy
fedcoin it's going to be worth 10 times
what it is in three days are you gonna
sit back they're gonna in the fomo and
and it's gonna work
let's jump to this next story this next
it's actually 8 30. I know we're gonna
have an incoming Sir James is finishing
up a radio interview he'll call it 8 40.
840. beautiful
well we'll keep talking about Bitcoin
Time Capsule for the future after the
dust settles and you guys start creating
a new currency make a currency that
deflates automatically the longer it
sits in your account so you're
encouraged to spend it to create you
mean no so I had a deflationary currency
it encourages uh circulation yeah
inflationary means its value goes up
uh well it actually so if you have a
dollar and it sits there tomorrow you'll
have 99 Cents
that's inflationary that's literally
what the dollar does and they do it for
the purpose of trying yes talking about
a coin that actually disappears into
nothing right right you're based that's
that's what like a default the dollar
does
one dollar in 1908 is where uh a dollar
today is worth like what three cents
compared to a dollar 100 years ago yeah
but that's because they printed a bunch
more but in this situation you'd print
20 million coins it's the same thing
it's in Reverse it's the same thing it's
the same no it's a deflationary currency
it's the same function it's the same she
just doesn't you should understand but
you're describing the same thing you
would never print a new one you'd have
them all right right you're just
describing a different means of doing
the same thing yeah
and it's not deflationary deflationary
means the value goes up not down the
value goes up
because they're harder to find yeah
I guess but you could also create more
of them I guess you're actually right on
that one if if the money disappears then
it becomes more scarce and more valuable
so you're not actually losing any value
and there is no incentive to spend in
fact the incentive is to hold on to it
because it's disappearing but they can
create but then you'll be able to create
more of it and it'll constantly keep
disappearing so it's like you don't want
to have it then it's like having an
expiration date on your money yeah to
increase the velocity because because
the biggest problem is wealth hoarding
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time